tonight on Brian Ross investigators
California prosecutors say this church
leader a self-proclaimed apostle used
his power over young women to turn them
into his sex slaves now for the first
time one of them speaks out naked during
sexual affairs describing how the man
she was taught to obey as Jesus on earth
beat her she refused his perverted
demands you can't tell him no you can't
tell him this isn't right plus the
latest on that deadly virus spreading
fast from China to dozens of countries
including the u.s. new cases are still
popping up around the world on a daily
basis what can Americans do to protect
themselves one of the country's leading
experts joins us and our shout for the
student journalists in Hong Kong on the
front lines of that city's protests even
after this young woman got shot with a
rubber bullet it turned to become from
the law and crime Network studios in New
York City's Herald Square this is Brian
Ross investigates good evening and
welcome tonight we're going to hear from
a young woman who says she was recruited
to be a sex slave for the powerful men
who run her church with the grooming
beginning she says at the age of nine
it's a sordid tale but one backed up by
disclosures in court papers following
the arrest and pending trial of her
church leader her name is so chill
Martin and prosecutors say she's among
dozens of young girls to be trafficked
by the powerful church leader over the
last decade but she's the first to come
forward and speak publicly please Jesus
he's Jesus here on earth he was the
purest most perfect man on earth nation
joaquin garcia is called the apostle by
the millions of followers who he claims
belong to his light of the world church
an evangelical fundamentalist church
active in every state in the United
States and in dozens of other countries
around the world so everything that I
was taught to do for him it wasn't wrong
it was it was a blood it was blessing it
was a blessing but now so chill Martin
says she knows better that what she did
for the Apostle was wrong very wrong and
now she's coming forward in this
interview and in a lawsuit set to be
filed suit claiming the Apostle turned
her into a sex slave and ordered her to
help him recruit young boys and girls
for sex trafficking
did you see times where there were girls
under the age of 17 who were involved in
a sexual relationship or having sex with
Mason yes all the time in which he was
yes everything yes essentially raping
them right yes I I was there you saw
that I saw that often occasionally often
it was an everyday thing so chill
Martin's account comes as the church
leader is already behind bars in Los
Angeles awaiting trial on sex
trafficking charges brought by the
California Attorney General he has
pleaded not guilty the type of crimes
that belong nowhere in our society from
human trafficking production of child
pornography oral copulation rape
statutory rape child molestation
extortion conspiracy and more so Jill
says she's now cooperating with the
California Attorney General and with the
FBI and federal prosecutors the first
alleged victim of Garcia to speak
publicly I was a member of the church
for thirty years of my life I was born
into the church fourth generation my
great grandparents my grandparents were
one of the first members of the Los
Angeles church the church is run like a
family business it was founded by
Garcia's grandfather in
Jara Mexico he was the first
self-proclaimed apostle a title he
passed on to his son Samuel so chill
says it was Samuel who first introduced
her to the dark side of the church I was
9 9 10 years old when I was taught and
taken to Samuel and you're you're right
when you say it's a dark place just
because even when you're that young you
know something's off no matter what they
tell you
but she says inside the church the young
girl is recruited for the Apostle are
considered special encouraged even by
their own mothers to serve it you think
that you're chosen and you're you're
taught that you're lucky you're lucky to
be there and that you're the rest of the
girls that you're around
Wow out of all of these girls and the
church thousands and thousands of
members of the church and this
congregation out of all of them I I'm
chosen when you're taken to a private
room or to one of his private homes or
his private properties and you're forced
to take your clothes off for them and
touch them and seduce them in a way that
an older woman would your mother was
actually encouraging you to do this she
took me yes she would buy things for me
and she would take me physically and
knowing what was going on yes and she
would speak to him before and after why
would she do that
hey she thought it was okay she herself
she was young she was she was with him
she was one of his concubines so I'm
guessing that she thought that it was
okay to do it later as a high school
student in Los Angeles attending John
Marshall High School so Joe says she was
then seduced and molested by Nessun
Garcia who was married at the time
but not yet crowned the apostle he would
caress my my buttocks and my waist and
the sides of my breasts so in my head
again I still try to believe that it
wasn't that bad but it's bad and I guess
if you want to call it that it is he
molested me at age 16 and I didn't see
it that way
so she'll says when Mason took over
running the church following the death
of his father the relationship grew more
extensive and weirder including
recording scenes of group sex with so
chill and underage girls naked during
sexual affairs and group sex and he
would record with phones and iPads and
tablets and he had his computer he would
download all of it and he would he would
keep that with him
in fact the California prosecutors have
said in court they have recovered scores
of the apostles phones and tablets and
computers with sex tapes of underage
children
there's devices that have content that
we've identified as child pornography
does it bother you that you're in those
videos it does just because in the
moment when you're there you think it's
a blessing but things came to a head so
chill Martin says when she refused to
perform a sex act on a fourteen-year-old
boy in front of the boy's mother and the
Apostle she says the Apostle was furious
at her refusal and gave her a beating
after the situation with him it's a
little boy he calls me back and that's
what happened he
he leaned me over and he he struck me
until I couldn't feel my right leg
you tell them to stop
you can't tell him to stop you can't
tell him no you can't tell him this
isn't right you can't tell him it hurts
you can't tell him you can't tell him
that you're unhappy you can't tell you
can't tell him that you're in pain you
can't tell him that you're confused you
can't say any of that lawyers for the
Apostle have already attacked so chill
Martin saying in court papers they have
uncovered new evidence of social
Martin's own criminal conduct saying she
groomed underaged girls in an attempt to
extort mr. Garcia showing them how to
pose sexy and allegedly telling others
she was in love with mr. Garcia and
repeatedly described him as her
everything when he asked you to be with
these young women minor girls he went
along with that you don't have a choice
you don't have a choice like everything
in my being my mind my my body
everything I was taught my entire life
was that that was okay it was done to me
was done to my mom it was done to all
those other girls that I grew up around
and their moms were okay with it so
chill Martin has now left the church and
is in the California witness relocation
program treated as an outcast by her
family with the church did not see her
wherever they can I lost my family I
lost friends I lost my Society I lost my
world I fell down I I was beat up I was
kicked I was emotionally physically
mentally the bravest thing I ever did
was get back up when I wanted to die and
that's what I feel happened so now that
I'm up I feel like it's my
responsibility
to keep going try all you want but the
truth is there and justice is there and
it's waiting for you we ask lawyers for
the church leader Garcia and other
officials of the church to respond to
the allegations of social Martin but our
calls were not returned in court papers
fired last month by the California
Attorney General prosecutors said they
have discovered even more evidence of
his sexual abuse of young boys and girls
thousands of pornographic images they
say evidence they say of how Garcia the
Apostle uses his position in the church
to satisfy his seemingly insatiable
appetite for young girls
up next the latest on that virus out of
China now called a global health
emergency we'll talk with one of the
country's leading experts
back now with a fast developing story
the world World Health Organization has
now declared that virus in China as a
global health emergency meaning it's a
serious threat to countries well beyond
China the death toll is now more than
170 with more than 8,000 people reported
to be infected in at least 19 countries
and those numbers seem to be growing
exponentially every day it's called the
corona virus Ground Zero traced to an
open-air market in the Chinese city of
Wuhan that sold exotic animals including
snakes and rats for their meat as the
virus spreads so do the concerns of
public health officials here in the US
and around the world the news has sent
the US stock market into a tailspin and
officials at the World Health
Organization today are trying to prevent
a coronavirus panic in the media over
the past few weeks we have witnessed the
emergence of a previously unknown
pathogen which has escalated into an
unprecedented outbreak and which has
been met by an unprecedented response as
I have said repeatedly since my return
from Beijing the Chinese government is
to be congratulated for the
extraordinary measures it has taken to
contain the outbreak despite the severe
social and economic impact those
measures are having on the Chinese
people so to that to get the story
straight about this virus were joined
again by dr. William Schaffner
Vanderbilt University one of the
country's foremost experts on preventive
medicine and communicable diseases and
doctor thank you for being here you're
on the phone as we break on this story
we talked last week you held out some
hope this might not be as bad as you had
feared but do you still feel that way
well I still have a great deal of hope
but it's appropriate determination that
we have this as an public health
emergency of international concern in
effect it will quarantine China and
reduce the travel to and from China
hoping to more confine this infection to
that country and reduce X
or tations to other parts of the world
today as you know dr. shafter there's a
report of another infected person in
Illinois a human to human transfer of
the virus what's the significance of
that well the important thing to
remember is that our public health
system in the United States is working
the patient had been informed she
reported her illness immediately she was
put in isolation and the public health
team was right away there's no further
spread at the present time we're doing
this for every single reported case the
clinicians and the public health people
are working hand in glove dr. Jeff there
a question for you from our control room
from executive producer Rhonda Schwartz
Rhonda doctor chef NARR we see folks all
around the world wearing face masks
there's advice on the Internet you
should be using bleach in your house
what can people do to try to protect
themselves well I think we need to take
a deep breath step back and recognize
that influenza which is in every state
is a much greater hazard to us than is
the corona virus at present masks are
not recommended by the CDC there are
really very scant data that they help
people in the community prevent
infection wash your hands
avoid people who are coughing and
sneezing and if you're ill ask yourself
two questions have I recently returned
from China have I had close contact with
someone who has recently returned from
China and if the answer to those two
questions is no you've got the flu not
coronavirus dr. Seffner for the night
Ramona virus is there any sort of
vaccine or treatment that can be found
at this point in the works Brian it's
going to be available in months assuming
that the vaccine work proceeds without a
problem
the scientists are collaborating
internationally to get that vaccine to
us as quickly as possible it's been
great being with you thank you so much
dr. Schaffner thank you so much for
being with us tonight this can be a
frightening time and your insights help
all of us to understand just what's
going on
up next our shout out for the student
journalists in Hong Kong on the front
lines
this week marked student press freedom
day to celebrate the contributions of
student journalists all over the world
we over the past year have recognized
the work of journalists at the high
school in parkland Florida in the wake
of the terrible shooting there and the
efforts by the students at the
University of Michigan in Ann Arbor
whose paper is now the only daily
newspaper in that city and tonight our
shout is for another group of student
journalists will put themselves
literally on the front lines braving
possible violence as they cover the
protests in the city of Hong Kong where
demonstrators have rallied against the
heavy hand of China at running their
City which was supposed to be
independent of Beijing the images of the
Hong Kong protesters facing off with
police have led to worldwide
condemnation Hong Kong and authorities
invasion a live image right now what's
happening there on the streets of Hong
Kong - it's all those young haunting
times you should all Tommy issue the pow
pow authorities fire tear gas and pepper
spray with the city's police
commissioner calling the demonstration
or riot and some of the most compelling
close-up footage of what's happening the
water cannons the tear gas the beatings
have come from a team of college
journalists in Hong Kong
Joanna Howe is one of them using her
iPhone and a small camera to record the
scene ready for anything we have gas
masks and helmets and let me ask you
this do you fear that you might be had
hurt covering all this because it's
become violent at some point with the
police and the protesters squaring off
I'm afraid of that and I got hurt in
November and I was I got hurt by a
rubber bullet when did you get hit and
how did it feel it felt painful it was
originally like this and then he turned
to become this the bullet hits you in
the leg Joanna is part of a group of
college-age journalism students who felt
the call to record and report on what is
in their city despite the risk of
getting hurt or arrested their online
outlet undergrad is run by Oscar Chow
why is it important for you to be out
there it's because the imaan of trainers
in different lines is it's not enough
and some of times the critical moment
are being captured by student journalist
only and I think we are trying to like
fulfill the demand of the journalists in
different lines make takfir of being
discovered Cho since the police call his
colleagues Black Journalists Horace we
think we are doing illegal things that's
why he would cause deep a trainers and
also they are thinking that we are
cooperating with the the protesters
dressed in black that's why did we cause
deep black generous Johanna ho says her
only real protection is the power of the
press label she wears proudly whenever
she is on the streets with the
protesters I guess it's hard to say it's
like fun to be different here because I
guess it's not a game
I guess it's it's recharging but it's
really rewarding the same time as I can
really feel that what am i doing is like
I can't impact to the society and
joining us now in the studio is Ariel -
the producer of Brian Ross investigates
who started herself as a student
journalist in Taipei Taiwan to see these
journalists in Hong Kong they're very
brave to do this right they it was
really awesome because joanna is only 20
and oscar is 19 and he's now the editor
in chief of undergrad which is their
publication and I myself started as a
student journalist - but the fact that
they're on the front line it's really
amazing because they're risking their
lives and is there a cultural thing to
challenge authority like that because
they could be arrested right not really
I don't think it's a culture thing and
like during the interview Joe and I did
tell us that she her parents didn't know
that she's actually reporting on the
front line until they saw her work and
they're still out there they're only
protection is wearing the press vest
mm-hmm yeah and the police have been
pretty brutal there haven't they
yeah I think one of the demands that
Hong Kongers are trying to make it
clearer is that they want the government
to investigate police brutality and
that's been the key theme for them and
she recovered from her injury the rubber
bullet hitting her in the leg
yes so far but I think that she's gonna
keep reporting and let's hope that she's
safe indeed yeah Aereo to a great peace
thanks for all your work and thanks for
being here tonight
preciate it very much so that's our
program for tonight thanks so much for
joining us we'll see you back here on
the law and crime Network next week
you